again our main event on nationalism is
an important value that Americans should
support uh arguing for the affirmative
Rich Lowry Rich please come to the stage
um
arguing for the negative Alex norasta
Alex please come to the stage
thank you
Jane please close the voting uh Rich you
have 15 minutes to defend the resolution
take it away rich
thank you very much so
in debates like this and really in any
form of political argument rhetoric Even
in our daily lives we really want people
to use the correct words for for things
right to not resort to euphemism and I'm
here to tell you this will never happen
and that this was brought home to me my
my uh home life not too long ago so my
daughter learned the word stupid which
is not the worst word in the world right
but she was quite delighted with herself
she's saying stupid all the time it's
just kind of annoying so yeah I said to
her you know why not instead of using
the word stupid why don't use the word
ill-considered instead right I'm the
editor-in-chief of National Review I
gotta try at least right so this didn't
work as you might expect stupid stupid
why don't you say you'll considered
stupid stupid stupid on it goes so then
one one morning it's around the time she
was getting potty trained and my wife
would put in a a pad in her pants just
in case extra insurance she gets up one
Saturday morning goes into the bathroom
you use of the toilet in a marvelous
fashion and then in an excess of zeal
throws in the pad flushes the whole
thing it backs up and it's a it's a
sewerish debacle in this this bathroom
when things go wrong you know in the
household it's always blamed on Me Maybe
correctly maybe not but I'm going in I'm
swabbing I'm mopping I'm doing the whole
nine yards and my wife's like Rich you
gotta talk to her she can't do this kind
of thing Rich talk I'm going to talk to
her you know after 20 minutes of
cleaning up I come out and I'm ready for
this this fantastic fantastic daughter
father moment I take her on my knee and
I say honey what did you do wrong you
said Daddy I did something
ill-considered
so it's it's a pleasure to be here I
want to thank Soho forum for putting on
this vent I want to thank Alex for being
here on the debate stage I think it'll
be a fun and hopefully Illuminating
um evening I didn't realize uh by the
way that this is such a reason oriented
event is slowly dawned on me Mia that
the link is to reason TV the reason
magazines on the uh on the the back of
the the seat so I guess I'm the
conservative Patsy's just walked into
this libertarian trap you know uh it
should have been a sign when Grant was
asked to sing songs about Freedom
instead of songs about National feeling
you know
um but I I'm a huge admirer of Frida of
uh reason Freedom too and and reason and
reason which I think is is easily the
second best political magazine in the
English language so and I also
appreciate all you uh being here Mark
Twain said the best audiences are
inquisitive well-informed and drunk so I
think we probably have two out of the
first three and we'll work on the third
across the street a little later okay so
let's talk about nationalism so there's
a common erroneous belief that
patriotism of the word is the word for
everything good and National feeling and
nationalism is the word for everything
bad and National feeling and and this is
just a erroneous and unsustainable
definition if we get technical for a
moment the root of patriot criticism the
Latin word Padre it's the same root as
patriarchy it means Fatherland right it
means love of land of our father love of
our own this is a natural uh and an
important sentiment nationalism is
closely related
um but is is something separate so
nationalism is the doctrine or the idea
that a distinct people United by a
common culture United by a common
history United very often by a Common
Language should govern a distinct piece
of territory distinct people distinct
territory now this might not sound like
an outlandish idea to you for a good
reason this defines the entirety of the
modern international system this is the
world we live in is defined by
nationalism right we live in a world
where distinct peoples have their
Sovereign borders and their own distinct
cultures is this a terrible thing is
this a bad thing no this is a good thing
and if you agree it's a good thing then
even if you didn't know it or not when
you came in these doors you are a
nationalist congratulations I have a
book to sell uh to you on Amazon right
now
um now
if you look at this the system compared
to the rest of the human human history
it's worked marvelously well it's
created more stability it's created more
International piece and it's created
more democracy entire books have been
written about this phenomenon Stephen
Pinker had a wonderful one several years
ago now
most people would support that system
but you don't have to right there are
alternatives to nationalism you can say
no our primary loyalty shouldn't be to
the nation it should be to tribe or to
Clan or to sect and this is the way it
was throughout most of human history and
still is in many places today look at
Afghanistan right there are a lot of
people in Afghanistan say no I'm not an
Afghan I don't even know whether that is
I'm a pashtune or I'm an aziri and this
is a very deeply felt loyalty obviously
as we've learned to our regret they'll
defend it uh very ferociously but it
makes it impossible to have a coherent
nation-state in Afghanistan and just
like Afghanistan many um a coherent
makes impossible to have a coherent
nation-state and just like Afghanistan
many failed states around the world lack
this kind of requisite nationalism to
make it work and even in this country a
tiny Fringe of a fringe there are people
who want to elevate a tribal loyalty
above the nation right the morons who
were marching with the tiki torches in
Charlottesville want to elevate race
Over The American Nation which I think
has been a terrible deal and an awful
mistake January 6 you look at that if
your reaction to that is you know what
that capital is ours it belongs to all
of us you know that box they bring out
when they're counting the electoral
votes they've done it for 200 years how
dare you how dare you interrupt
interrupt that and how dare you disgrace
us before the world that's at bottom
that's a nationalist sentiment there are
all sorts of other reasons to oppose
those uh people but that is a
nationalist
um sentiment so maybe you don't want to
be a nationalist or or a tribalist well
there are there are other Alternatives
there have been great Empires throughout
human history many quite long long
lasting the Ottomans right the habsburgs
the Russians right these Empires had
many things to recommend them but they
were not not one of them was a democracy
and they depended on coercion to hold
themselves together because they had
captive peoples captive Nations who
didn't want to be governed by the center
um represented by another uh people or
Nation they wanted to govern themselves
and as soon as the coercion gave way
these Empires
um split up now we want to take this in
the current context again you don't have
to be a nationalist you can look at the
conflict between Russia where Vladimir
Putin is a Nero imperialist bent on
restoring as much of the Russian Empire
as he can or you can be with the
ukrainians right you can be with
zelinski and the ukrainians who are
involved in a classic people's struggle
to defend their land to defend their
sovereignty to defend their culture and
I submit to you those aren't bad things
those aren't small-minded things those
are things that are crucial to every
people in the world and what they are
doing is hugely
admirable again you're not a nationalist
you can root for the the British
colonial Empire against Gandhi you're
not a nationalist you can vote for
Napoleon and his root for Napoleon and
his Imperial project against the
European countries that resisted him in
war after War and the Napoleonic era
you're not a nationalist you can be a
sympathizer of the Soviet Union and not
elect valessa and other nationalists in
Eastern Europe who wanted their
countries uh their Nations to be free
now let's bring around to the United
States really quickly and just look at
the history of nationalism in this
country the American Revolution was a
nationalist Revolution
the American said
we've lived here in these Shores now for
130 years whatever it is we've taken on
a distinct identity of our own and we
should be allowed to govern ourselves
just a classic based lowest common
denominator nationalist sentiment now
not everyone agreed with them right the
country according John Adams divided in
thirds a third Tories a third Patriots
third in between and the Taurus no we'll
still be loyal to this this uh this the
crown this other political Authority
across the ocean but the Nationalist I
submit to you uh we're right after the
war given their experience of dealing
with the Continental Congress during the
war and afterwards Washington and
Hamilton said you know what we need a
national government worthy of the name
or this project is going to fail and
bring discredit to
um
democracy Evermore we have to make it
work there's a constitutional convention
the Constitution is drafted and the
nationalists make the case for adopting
at the Anti-Federalist honorable people
sincere people passionate people
intelligent people the library of
America collected their writings not too
long though they're worth reading but
they were wrong the nationalists were
right we needed a Constitution which has
become the sheetrock of our sovereignty
uh going forward and then of course the
Civil War we had the Southern Fire
readers believing no there was not
really a national compact that had to be
adhered to the national government was a
threat to slavery and they had to go uh
their own way and Lincoln and his allies
were right that this this Insurrection
had to be crushed so this all this is to
say if you go through American history
whether it's Washington Hamilton whether
it's John Quincy Adams Lincoln TR
um they largely had it right even FDR
obviously I don't support his economic
policies but it was his International
Vision that's created this world of
nation states that I've been describing
Now American nationalism has from the
beginning been more liberal than other
versions of Nash nationalism around the
world I mean liberal obviously in the
classical liberal sense and a lot of
scholars believe that what American
nationalism is is what what they call
Civic nationalism right this is this is
the belief that the foundations of our
nationalism are shared citizenship
Devotion to our Civic ideals and loyalty
to our institutions this is again a very
basic nationalism but at the very least
at the very least everyone should
support that and if you support that you
are a nationalist now I'd submit to you
cultural nationalism is also very
important and let me illustrate what I
mean by that just hypothetically let's
say on the steps of the Paris opera
house tonight a European American meets
an African-American might be from
different regions of the country might
have different politics but they
instantly instantly have more in common
than anyone else around them they speak
the same language so that they can be
assured that they understand one another
they wear the same kind of clothes
broadly they like the same kind of food
and they have even if they know don't
don't recognize it this enormous door of
shared cultural knowledge whether it's
from you know what Britney Spears is
posting on Instagram uh right now or
whether it's who won the Super Bowl last
year or whether it's uh phrases that
even if they again are not aware of it
that go go go back to the king's James
came King James Bible which is the most
important book for so long in our early
history so again is this a bad thing
it's a good thing it should be fostered
and protected it lends a cultural
coherence to this country it gives us
social trust which is so important for
the market uh the free market to work
for democracy to work and again places
like Afghanistan that don't have this do
not have democracies if they don't have
this basic level of coherence and social
trust they get Civil Wars they get coups
they get ethnic cleansing so we need
this uh these these pillars of
commonality yes nationalism can be
abused everything that's natural and
Powerful can be abused love can be
abused right Love's a wonderful thing it
can become possessiveness and even
violence the opposite of love so it
needs to be true love and carefully
Define and have guardrails Christianity
I'm I'm a Christian just there are many
many examples of this but just look at
the Crusades and the enormities that
were committed in the name of my God
does that mean I shouldn't be a
Christian no it means that we should
have a properly uh defined Christianity
so in short turning our back on the very
basic and unobjectionable and necessary
things that hold us together especially
at a time of great political contention
and division based on a hostile
misunderstanding of the idea of
nationalism would be to say the least
ill considered thank you
thank you
[Applause]
well thank you very much to Soho Forum
to uh Gene Epstein for putting this
together to reason for co-hosting for
Nick for his great introduction and for
Rich for being here today
now there are many books on nationalism
I put those books into three broad
categories the first are informative but
dry and descriptive academic tomes the
second are Breezy easy to read and bad
works of a historical propaganda the
third group of books are well written
informative and support nationalism I
put Rich's book into third category
indeed if you want to read the best case
for nationalism in book form I suggest
that you pick up Rich's book
however that does not mean that I agree
with it rich advocates for a benign
nationalism that doesn't exist in the
real world Rich's nationalism is
theoretical and bears almost no
relationship to nationalism as it
actually exists real nationalism as it
exists in the world is often and mostly
A Primitive statist protectionist
anti-capitalist frequently and on often
of course physenophobic and often
ethnocentric proto-ideology of quote My
Tribe best your tribe bad unquote with a
tribe being the core of the ideology the
only individual who counts as the chief
of the tribe it's an ideology of group
rights that denigrates individualism in
favor of an abstraction known as a tribe
or in this case the nation and by Nation
I mean a literal tribe of genetically
similar individuals with a Common
Language culture religion and ethnicity
this is why the Latin root of the word
nationalism is nashio which means birth
ethnicity race of people tribe or other
group of related people or things now I
like that rich separates his benign
version of natural nationalism from the
jingoistic and more nasty variety but
nationalism almost always not a hundred
percent of the time but almost always
veers in this nasty jingoistic status
Direction which is exactly the variety
we see popular amongst most American and
foreign nationalists today and in the
past which is not this type of
nationalist if all nationalists were
like Rich we wouldn't be having this
debate today but the difference between
riches nationalism and nationalism is it
actually exists is why we're here the
great failure of Rich's project is that
he builds a nicer theoretical version of
nationalism it does not deal with
nationalism as it actually exists in the
world and in the minds of nationalists
nationalism is the ideology that paves a
right-wing road to serfdom
unlike other opponents of nationalism I
am going to concede a point up front to
Rich nationalism is an ancient
proto-ideology that is likely hardwired
into our DNA to some extent it's
primordial nationalism was not invented
in Europe shortly after the printing
press and it is not a modern ideology
nationalism can't be erased any more
than any other aspects of human nature
could be erased and we should not try
nationalism has a weaker hold on humans
and other parts of our biology such as
love for one's children which is why
Nations must coerce their citizens to
contribute to other Nationals in the
state through taxation conscription
forced labor or Force attendance in
government schools while few people have
to be coerced to care for the children
well we do what we should do is build
and reinforce institutional and cultural
walls around nationalism to limit its
destructive impact and this is one
reason why the United States is an
exceptional country country our
ancestors built walls around nationalism
and constrained its ability to ruin this
great country constitutional limitations
that reduced the power of majorities and
a dedication to individual rights not
group rights or national rights were
inspired by an ideology of Classical
liberalism not an appeal to her internal
myth of a Nation that's because the
United States is not a nation
represented the state represented by a
state it's not a nation-state has never
been a nation-state
can never be a nation-state the founding
documents of this country did not create
a nation-state and the founders could
not have done so even if they wanted to
the United States was born a country
with an ideological underpinning a
creedal country with civic identity as
academics say not a national one Bound
by ties of blood or a near uniform
centrally planned culture like many of
the nations in Europe the United States
has a Creed or broad Enlightenment
classical liberal ideology adherence is
certain principles with a few cultural
characteristics and Broad commonality
we're not unique in this respect Canada
Australia New Zealand and others are
similar but the U.S takes it the
furthest other countries particularly
those in Europe and some in Asia are
founded as nation states where the
states represent a traditionally settled
tribal or ethnic group the United States
was founded in ideology nation states
are found in ideas of blood borders and
centrally managed culture regardless of
the theoretical definitions of
nationalism that we've heard we must
deal with Miracle real world nationalism
and judges effects we can't judge an
ideology by the intentions of its
Advocates we rightly judge communism by
its awful real world effects and mock
Communists you say the disasters of
Communism aren't the result of Real
communism we should do the same to
nationalists who claim that the awful
real world effects of nationalism aren't
real nationalism I'm going to highlight
six Common Real World effects of
nationalism that are major downsides
from this perspectives of American
traditional conservatives and
Libertarians then you can compare those
downsides to the benefits that rich
described to see if nationalism is worth
it now just to repeat I'm not arguing
that rich supports all of these effects
but these are the common and sometimes
unintentional effects of nationalism we
have to judge nationalism by its effects
not by the intention intentions of its
well-intended and moderate Advocates
like rich the first downside of
nationalism is that it increases
centralized state power and nationalism
to State representing a nation known as
a nation-state is the only organization
that counts because it represents the
entire nation individualism is not
important individual rights don't matter
and a nation's government does and
should determine everything regardless
of desires of the centers National
decisions are made by the state this is
especially true in times of distress
when nationalists claim to quote
ReDiscover the essence of the nation
unquote and seek to control its
embodiment the state as the only real
source of value and a refuge in times of
desperation the second effect of
nationalism is it attends to concentrate
state power in a single person the
leader nationalists often conflate the
nation with that of an individual
political leader who is a nationalist
frequently a strong man sometimes a
dictator and other times a king probably
because the nation is just an
abstraction that requires a totem of
some kind to be real in the minds of men
this is why schopenhauer described
monarchy as a natural form course it's
also why other large non-state
organizations today are often strongly
identified with the person leading them
Twitter Elon Musk for example
a charismatic strong leader who stands
above quote Petty unquote individual
distinctions and who represents strength
he requires more power who disregards
small concerns like individual liberty
who builds a cult of personality and who
is the representative of the nation fits
the bill and we see this again and again
and nationalist governments throughout
history and across the world today the
third common effect of nationalism is
more State control over the economy
after all the nation knows best and its
government will do whatever it thinks is
in the National interest or you know
more accurately whatever is in the best
interest of nationalist politicians it's
no mistake that National conservatives
as they call themselves A Day in the
United States favor industrial policy
protectionism high taxes close borders
pro-union policies a large welfare state
praise the New Deal even and desire more
State control over the economy
increasing State control of the economy
is partly ideological and partly just a
byproduct of the increasingly
centralized State the nationalists
demand we see without economic
protectionism like tariffs on foreign
products such as steel for vague
National Defense reasons or making sure
all baby formula is made in the United
States with disastrous consequences this
is the same today as it was in the Haiti
of nationalism from the late 19th
through to of the late 19th century to
World War II
the fourth effect of nationalism is more
government control over the private
lives of citizens and Central planning
of culture from the French Revolution
originating the term nation building in
France and the central planning of
language to Vladimir Putin and Russia
and dozens of nationalist leaders in
between they all use the state to force
the preferred version of a centrally
planned culture on society the most
common vehicle for this is through State
education system that instills
nationalist values and poses uniform
language or linguistic guidelines and
subsidizes certain cultural norms over
others the powerful nation-state Canon
does impose different values and
dissenters be damned the fifth effect of
nationalism is the glorification of
militarism and War and lesser hostility
between nations through trade Wars
tearing up of Arm Control treaties for
no good reason
judged by the numbers of deaths caused
by different types of governments in the
20th century just focusing on
governments murdering their own citizens
nationalism is second only to Communism
and that excludes the Nationalist crimes
against humanity during the age of
Imperialism when whereby nationalists
murdered over 50 million people
according to historian RJ Rummel as
historian Douglas porch noted quote
colonialism was not as Lenin claimed the
highest stage of capitalism rather it
was the highest stage of nationalism
we see nationalist Wars more vividly
today and Russia's attempt to conquer UK
Ukraine as part of a nationalist
irredentism to reconstitute the Russian
Empire by bringing the quote quote fake
ethnicity of ukrainians unquote back
into the Russian fold as Russian
nationalists say it's no mistake that so
many nationalists around the world
admired Putin prior to his invasion such
as Dutch nationalist tiribaudet French
nationalist Marine Le Pen Italian
Nationalist and prime minister Giorgio
Maloney and former Italian Prime
Minister bolusconi who still defends
Putin after the invasion and many
American National conservatives as they
call themselves some American National
conservatives are Nat Khan's slobbered
over Putin in part because his military
recruitment advertisements showed
Russians as extremely manly
now in his book Rich prays as Teddy
Roosevelt as an American nationalist a
man whose greatest accomplishments were
support for the income tax burdening
successful American firms with mountains
of red tape trust busting building a
large obsolete Navy creating new
bureaucracies creating national parks
and advocating for U.S entry into just
about every war going on around the
globe and accomplishing many Feats of
great physical strength now as a
Libertarian none of those nationalist
so-called achievements thrilled me and
they shouldn't throw the traditional
conservatives listening today
the sixth common effect of nationalism
is ethnic chauvinism and to a
disturbingly frequent extent genocide
Slaughters and nationalists turkey Mass
death and nationalist China two world
wars were caused by nationalists with
revengeous dreams historian aristide
zolberg went as far as to call the
formation of new nation-states as quote
a refugee generating process unquote to
expel groups of people who are not
members of the new nation not every
nationalist government can commits
genocide or engages in ethnic chauvinism
but not every Communist Regime causes a
Great Famine either we shouldn't give
nationalists a pass any more than we
should give Communists a pass still we
should be extremely skeptical and oppose
Communist governments everywhere for
this and other reasons just as we should
be extremely skeptical and oppose
nationalist governments with such a
large potential style inside the
nationalism the benefits must be greater
to justify adopting such an ideology
what are the upsides we've heard about
feelings of belonging that will lead to
National greatness that pay off mainly
in the form of magic words does not
justify the potential downsides through
the equivalent of asking a person to
risk their life Freedom material
possessions today for abstract feelings
in the future that probably won't arrive
do you feel better and more connected to
other American strangers When Donald
Trump who Embrace nationalism as
president the Trump caused American
solidarity to increase just the opposite
nationalism is a schismatic ideology
that pulls citizens apart from one
another instead of binding them together
me and a belonging come from family
friendships real communities of people
who know each other Hobbies career and
other personal relationships not from
Devotion to a national abstraction some
of you may be thinking that the six
common effects of nationalism is going
to sound a lot like those of Communism
you'd be correct those downsides are
also not unique to nationalism or
communism but nationalism seems to make
a virtue out of these downsides and
gives a legitimate patina to them at the
very least nationalism doesn't even
acknowledge the downside risks
nationalism is to the right wing what
communism is to the left wing poorly
reasoned utopianism that often lead to
some of the worst crimes against
humanity communism promised material
prosperity and equality for all and fail
dramatically what is nationalism promise
but some good feelings or meaning tied
to an abstraction
in an ideologically founded country like
the U.S nationalism is a disuniting
force and not a United one nationalism
here builds walls around different
groups and defines political opponents
or other groups as less American than
others nationalism is an exclusionary
ideology not an inclusive one
nationalism often defines a country in
terms of what it's not usually
foreigners but that frame is easily
applied to Defying fellow American
citizens as not real nationalists either
Claremont senior fellow Glenn Elmers an
American Nationalist and writer at a
nationalist publication wrote in 2021
that the 80 million Americans who voted
for President Joe Biden in 2020 were
quote not Americans in any meaningful
sense of the term unquote and
claremont's Charles R Kessler has argued
that the U.S is experiencing a cold
Civil War
these nationalists believe that half of
American voters have betrayed the nation
they obviously don't care about building
National solidarity if they wanted to
build National solidarity and harness
good feelings for National greatness
they would be trying to bring the
country together instead of trying to
label half of their fellow countrymen as
non-americans or Un-American where is
this benign nationalism and uniting
nationalism that rich speaks of
certainly not in the mines or on the
lips of nationalists thank you
thank you
five minutes five minutes of rebuttal uh
Rich Larry
thank you thank you Alex that was uh
forceful and comprehensive so I'm not
going to be able to get to everything
but uh first of all I can't answer for
everything that any idiot says uh on the
uh the the internet or any other
publication or in uh nor am I
responsible for anything that certain
former president United States uh might
might say so the contention
the United States is not a nation-state
and this is really breaking news should
we not be in the United Nations or are
we falsely listed among the 150 whatever
it is Nations at the the United Nations
why do we have borders if we're not a
nation say why do we have a military
what's the military doing how does an
ideal
have and build a military and deploy a
military as possible that that's uh uh I
got to try to write my head around that
one we have trade policies we have rules
around citizenship we have political
traditions and that are that are written
down all these are constituent parts of
a Nation so I think Alex's argument
fails at that most basic level because
if he acknowledges we're a nation-state
then he has to acknowledge well we
should feel some loyalty to this
nation-state and to its traditions and
guess what that's Civic nationalism
we're all nationalists so he has to to
engage in a really a reality defying
um Act of rhetorical gymnastics to say
we're we're not
um a nation-state and then you know that
that nationalism is inherently
centralizing well yes no I I think
saying that proves too much again uh
without um sorry the comprehensive way
that he Alex feels those necessary to
make his his case I think for
understandable rhetorical reasons I mean
he'd opposed the adoption of the
Constitution that was a hugely
centralizing event to have a
constitution again the Anti-Federalists
they opposed it for that reason so that
this is the charter of our liberties the
charter of our our sovereignty the
basics of our our Civic nationalism
Alice would oppose it if he's true to
his premises again I think he has to go
this extreme because he knows he'd
otherwise have to give too much away the
Civil War
right hugely centralizing event hugely I
mean there are some Libertarians who
actually they don't like Lincoln because
he was a centralizer because he's like
actually no we do have a national Camp
compact that cannot be broken and the
national government has integrity and
legitimacy I think those things are
obviously true now it doesn't mean you
have to go to uh the the excesses that
progressives do I think the Constitution
means something and uh should limit the
central government in important ways but
it does establish
a central government of a nation-state
and then so if nation states are so
terrible like they're inherently
illiberal and they they uh uh are going
to automatically murder all their
citizens you know one group's gonna
murder another what's the alternative I
mean look at England so in the Middle
Ages you had all these little uh
kingdoms many kingdoms you had uh you
know Wessex and Murcia and northumbria
there's kind of interesting places to
read about was this better
for England was this better for freedom
for peace for the market to have it all
divided up of course not they're Waging
War on each other constantly and it was
good for Freedom was good for liberalism
that you got a nation-state a true
nation state in England and in fact in
the 19th century Alex again he was
portrayed all nationalists they they
want to kill people the nationalists in
the 19th century were liberals
they oppose the empires that were
repressing
um they they believed deeply in a
quality of citizenship these are honored
people of manzini and mazarik to believe
they're monsters is is completely
um it just it just makes no sense
whatsoever and again if you take his
premises seriously seriously let's
reconstitute all the empires so we can
get rid of these nation-states get them
back into the Soviet Union get them back
into the ottoman uh Empire maybe
Napoleon should have established an
Empire and just held Europe
um under its way and then and then I'm
running out of time he's got me started
he's got me started folks so this idea
that militarism and warfare started
because of nation states and
nationalists
it's completely a historical you know
the research goes back there's some
people think uh oh tribes they just sat
around they shared they were so nice to
each other no like 30 of the young
adults die by acts of violence
um Empires look at the Roman Empire we
haven't some people have an idealist uh
version of the Roman Empire where you
know we like the speeches and the Togos
it was a military state it crushed
people and then brought them in that's
what it did and it was an Empire it
wasn't the nation-state the constituent
peoples eventually wanted to be free it
was really messy when they got free it
took a while to get what we live in
again a world largely defined their
exceptions they're terrible I oppose
them largely defined by Sovereign
Nations that have Sovereign borders that
have a quality of citizenship and
believe this this is the key Insight
going back to the founders
governments belong to Nations not the
other way around the Nations belong to
the people that's a key nationalist
insight and then finally again
um Alex should should oppose the
nationalists in Ukraine
you should oppose them what are they
doing defending their land defending
their sovereignty what small-minded
people what right do they have
to just defend a nation-state
uh Alex okay thank you Mitch
yeah Alex you get you get an extra
minute and a half okay
rich took an extra minute and a half
well you know it was a minute and a half
rich
the phrase nation state is pretty weird
sounding isn't it right when you first
heard it sounds pretty redundant doesn't
it to American ears well it's not
redundant in Europe it actually means
something very specific it is a state
founded to represent a specific
ethnicity
a specific tribe and group of people you
notice how rich Define the term
patriotism and went to the Latin root a
patriotism father why didn't he do that
for nationalism
because a Latin root of nationalism is
nashio which means ethnicity and Europe
This is clear everybody knows about this
it's obvious over there it's only in
America where nationalists can pretend
that it has nothing to do with that or
it's separate from that the US is a
country obviously it is a state
obviously like lots of other countries
around the world and throughout history
that are not nation states but are
well-functioning well-governed free and
prosperous like Canada Switzerland
Australia New Zealand and these other
places that are not nation states the
United States was not founded to
represent a particular ethnicity it was
not founded for that unless you believe
the 1619 project nonsense about that it
was not founded for that the United
States is different we are founded on an
ideological backdrop based on universal
values the Declaration of Independence
was not say it didn't it doesn't use the
word Nation it establishes a new
government it establishes and separates
from another government the U.S
Constitution only uses the term Nation
twice to represent something called The
Law of Nations which is international
law although enforce international law
and how they'll have relationships with
foreign Nation doesn't describe itself
in that at all we talked about
nationalism and all the good outcomes
well we got to take all the bad outcomes
worth it now obviously modern
nationalists didn't invent War but
nationalism is an ancient ideology it
goes back very far we both agree on that
point
Alternatives that rich mentioned tribes
Clans Empires
um that are that he said are coercive
well the news is all states are coercive
all states are coercive nation-states
use coercion all the time they use it
for conscription for Taxation and
everything like that it's not like
nation states or everybody holding hands
with the same feelings about stuff going
together in total solidarity that's like
nonsense nobody buddy like that you get
five people that you get three people
together they can't agree on anything
and just because we all come from the
same background we're supposed to be
going forward without coercion if that
were the case why do we have why does
any nation state have an income tax they
should just pay their money out of
solidarity with their fellow Nationals
to support all these great magic words
that are out there
the alternative to a nation states is
not tribes or Clans or Afghanistan but a
country like the United States
which is not a nation-state it is a
country it is a state it has Traditions
but it is not a nation-state and a
definition of it rich in his book cites
frequently some of the great National
Scholars like Anthony Smith to try to
approve the point that nationalism is
about culture of course Anthony Smith's
great book is called the ethnic origin
of Nations that's what it's about that
is what these people agree on that's the
Latin root of it
the Anti-Federalists
created the Bill of Rights
they inserted that into the Constitution
because they were concerned about
individual liberties when there was a
debate about the Constitution I think
the Constitution has worked out well I
think the part that has worked out the
best is the part that was instituted by
the uh Anti-Federalists when we talk
about when Rich mentioned a lot of the
Nationalist politicians in American
history of Myers but TR Lincoln uh FDR
he left Woodrow Wilson off the list
probably are arguably the most
nationalist American president ever got
us involved in World War One
uh created nationalist programs to try
to assimilate immigrants to some kind of
like special centrally planned ordeal
that didn't work uh lauded by
nationalists at the time uh supported
all the major Progressive policies just
about that Teddy Roosevelt supported
disagreed about the League of Nations
but that's about it
what's interesting is this denigration
of Civic nationalism if you want to talk
about how we have something in common uh
Civic National by the way is just like
oxymoronic phrase doesn't really make
any sense we have a civic identity in
this country we have an ideological
identity and that's good enough we don't
need big words that come from Europe
about trying to bind us all together in
some kind of mythical made-up ethnic
past to make us a successful country
um rich is right and almost anything can
be bad love can be bad right it can lead
to bad things we call that abuse we call
that stalking
nationalism is the stalking is to
stalking what uh it's uh patriotism is
to love
thank you
[Applause]
thanks to you both we get to the now the
Q a portion of the evening and there is
a mic uh for you to line up to uh you
guys can ask each other a question at
any time uh during the Q a uh you maybe
want to wait for the audience to ask
questions before you do but you can
exercise that option now uh do do either
of you want to ask the other a question
at this point uh or do you want to wait
for a bit looks like we want to wait uh
and I I want to take a moderators
prerogative to ask you each a question
uh Alex uh you you are saying that I
take it that the word nationalism is
should be expunged from your vocabulary
or put it in terms of question the the
uh the sort of thing that rich talks
about which is uh uh an identification
with the tradition of the Constitution a
gen identification with the tradition of
the founding fathers an identification
with the spirit of the American
Revolution uh with uh with with all that
we that you uh perhaps as libertarian
might value in the American tradition uh
you uh you you you value it it matters
to you uh and uh so you and I are
Americans but uh are you saying that
none of that should uh should mean that
you're introducing the word nationalism
it's out of your vocabulary altogether
nationalism is out of my vocabulary I
love the American founding I think the
Constitution is great the Declaration
but this is these are not the behaviors
of a nation-state or nationalism I'm a
patriotic American I love my country I
love it because it's lovable
I love it not because I was born here or
I'm an American if I was born somewhere
else I'd want to come here I love the
principles of it those are the things
that make us I think unique otherwise
we're just like every other uh you know
every other sort of nation-state in
Europe and we're not like that we
couldn't be like that at the time of the
fat 1790 only 60 percent of people
living in the United States were of
English descent another 20 were various
Europeans another 20 percent were black
Africans what is the natio what is that
group that was being founded that was
nationalists there were Americans but
they were not bound together in a nation
in any meaningful sense of the term
certainly not what the Latin root of the
term means
so uh you referred to kind of how
exclusionary nationalism is so so let's
look at a couple American National
um symbols and heroes I just just
curious whether you consider them
exclusionary the American flag is that
exclusionary the Pledge of Allegiance a
statement of basic American creed is
that exclusionary our greatest national
hero George Washington is he
exclusionary
no
thank you
okay
um question could also just call them
American instead of national I mean
America is a nation and this is another
thing curious so is it the term that
trips you up that you're being very
specific about nation state or you
actually think we're not a nation like
not a country like not a nation not a
country country and Nation aren't the
same meaning
why why did you have the why did you go
to the Latin root for the word
patriotism but not for nationalism to
make your definition early on so first
of all you're saying nation and country
are different things where so in America
so I've never heard this before yeah
that's because you need to talk to more
Europeans who understand the distinction
that's why it's oddly redundant in
America to say nation state it trips
people out they're like why are you
saying the same word twice because
they're Americans it means the same
thing but you go to Europe you talk to
people overseas nation state means a
state founded for a particular ethnicity
and tribe to represent them but see so
so you're saying so we're a country so
you're saying because in in Europe there
was more of an ethnic basis to the
founding of Nations we can't be a nation
because we are more open Nation I mean
we're just we we have a different
iteration of our nationalism which is
one thing that makes it good right
it's not bad
because it's it's different that's a
good thing about it and you're playing a
definitional game to try to deny that
obviously We're a nation because you
fear if we have We're a nation we have
National symbols and national heroes no
they have to be American don't use the
word Nation or nationalism you're
playing a word game to try to support
your point it's what the word means why
can't you just say patriotism why can't
you just say that we're not bound
together by this mystical nonsense we're
bound together by a Civic ethos no uh no
George Washington is real he's a
national hero he was a center he's just
he's he's a source of coherence he's a
unifying figure now I think you
inherently find that well it's bad
we all believe and we can't have that
but he is a national hero country hero I
don't think that heroes are bad but the
word Nation means something specific
which is why it is so often tied up in
people's minds with brutality with
genocide with war with ethics exclusion
with all these things you write about
this in your book
Richard you have the last word on that I
have a question for you rich uh uh in
particular one of the things that
bothers me as an economist is uh that I
do and I'm picking up on something that
Alex mentioned which you didn't get a
chance to respond to specifically which
is that uh that the Nationalist
viewpoint does seem to lead inevitably
into a disturbing tendency on the part
of many conservatives probably and
hopefully not you to to to impose
protectionism that uh that really that
you that that you're appealing and it's
so such an easy sell to so many
Americans you're nodding so I need an
elaborate how how do you uh react to
that problem I agree look it's not um uh
I don't agree with with everyone on the
center right right I I agree with that
it's probably like 80 of stuff but
obviously agree yet we disagree on 20
and the same thing with a lot of people
who call them Nash themselves
nationalists my test is kind of the
Nationalist test for policy is it in
America's interest okay
um that should be the first test Alex
has an entirely different view of
immigration policy than I do I assume he
thinks it's in America's interest
everything I've read that's kind of a
nationalist test is it good for the the
country uh the nation
um and I I think these people they
believe I think rightly that there was
um an over emphasis on just oh it's free
trade it's got to be by definition good
I mean there's some people in that in
the room agree with that but it's to be
subjected to this test is it really in
our interest is it serving our interests
particularly trade arrangements with
China if the answer is no then I I don't
support a free trade approach in in that
regard the answer is yes I'm I'd support
free trade and I mostly mostly do but
the test is is it is it does it serve
our interests does it serve uh the
interests of our people just if it shuts
down factories in certain areas of the
country but then it leads to better uh
deal for American consumers that's a
kind of a trade-off then who is we at
this point because some people are
losing their jobs and and feeling
intense pain and they have to move to
get better jobs so how do we know
whether it's in our interests I mean
these are Prudential questions but if it
serves the overall uh interest of the
country
um I think that and there's pain I mean
that's terrible you might want to do
things to mitigate it or you might might
just consider it inevitable I mean this
is why I disagree with the the natcons
it's just not the case that that there's
been
um uh totally equal economic progress
across every industry and every
geographic location in the United States
and that's your standard you're gonna
you're gonna kill
um economic dynamism and growth just
just really quickly I was cleaning out
my mom's house when she was moving to
Assisted Living I found these um uh
these old letters my great grandfather
who turns out was the the editor of a
republican newspaper so I guess it runs
in the genes somehow but I found all
these letters he he was writing my
grandfather automobiles are terrible son
this is the worst thing all they do is
kill people they're disgusting why won't
they go away why why is he so anti-car
and she said well he rent he he owned
the hotel at the rail Depot you know on
the highway came and bypassed it so of
course he hated cars but if you give in
to that sentiment he was hurt by that
economic advance but obviously cars and
highways were were good for the
country's overall interest okay uh
comment from you Alex the the overall
overwhelming feeling amongst National
conservatives and nationalists is uh to
follow the economic policies of Woodrow
Wilson and FDR we see this again and
again with the NAT cons we see with sore
abermari right what was this phrase I'm
a pro-life new dealer and that kind of
nonsense I mean if you had told me like
10 years ago that the most advanced
guard of energetic conservatives who
support Trump and JD Vance and Blake
Masters and all these other natcons and
nationalist politicians on the right are
a bunch of new deal lovers like I would
have told you oh that's crazy like if
you put that into a movie I'd have to
walk out of the theater because it's so
ridiculous but here we are there is
something about a group in ideology that
wants to concentrate state power in an
individual or in a political party or in
some kind of mystical ideal that pushes
many of them to support state control
over the economy and that's what we see
you want to take a look at what
nationalists are going to do or try to
do when they get power in the United
States you know look at Woodrow Wilson
or FDR it's a pretty good game plan a
question from the audience now please
ask your question ask a question and
address it to whomever you would like if
it is going to be addressed to a
particular person on stage
the question is addressed to both
when does a country or a nation cross
the line into an Empire and do you think
the United States crossed that line
um sounds like it's addressed to Alex
Moore but so Alex want to check it first
so uh
and I disagree about what a nation means
so uh I would say that the U.S certainly
has something close to an Empire with
its military bases and foreign
intervention and massive numbers of Wars
failed Wars mostly started by
nationalists over the course of the 20th
and early 24th century so I think you
can make that argument that the United
States certainly has a large presence
around the world and a northern amount
of power but of course this was pushed
by a lot of nationalist politicians it's
this notion that you can't be a
nationalist if you support aggressive
Wars against other nations is like
ludicrous
like that's ludicrous of course they do
all the time what happens when two
Nations disagree with each other over
something well oftentimes they go to war
does that mean they're not nationalists
anymore
of course they are
they disagree so you're stopping a
nationalist when when you stop being
concerned with governing yourselves and
you want to go govern someone else and
this can be a legitimately a fuzzy area
but Napoleon was not a nationalist
Hitler was not a nationalist right they
wanted an Empire they wanted a European
wide Empire so that you know in between
the the
um uh the the extremesan you can argue
about the middle but those are clearly
Imperial uh projects now in the United
States we
um and this was a failing of ours you
know we we tended that way
um in the late 19th and early 20th
century Philippines a prime example
um you know I think
um if you look where we are now these um
these bases they're desired by uh these
countries you know if you're Japan or
Taiwan or anyone on the perimeter of
China which has historically had Empire
after Empire wants to restore uh an
Empire just the way Vladimir uh Putin
does they want us there it's not like we
have a gun to their head please let us
station troops there they want us uh
there because we will they they Trust
just us we'll see they trust us to
defend their National sovereignty when
is under threat from a political entity
that has zero respect for it I'm kind of
hung up on well Hitler wasn't a
nationalist thing um okay the head of
the National Socialist German Workers
Party just because he wanted to conquer
some neighbors I mean does that mean
because France conquered Africa in the
19th century they weren't a nation-state
all of a sudden no I mean that was not a
nationalist project why not conquering
other countries is not or other
repressing other people is not a
nationalist it's a colonial you I think
it used a clear Colonial that's
appropriate you got the definition right
on that one and if you say
um you know what I think there is a
there's a superior race that should
ethnically cleanse uh all of Europe and
mass murder the Jews and be led by a
charismatic madman that doesn't make you
a nationalist it makes you a Nazi right
there's a huge difference what is is and
I think this is what you kind of think
mazzini you know who wanted Italian uh
freedom and Italian it must have been a
kind of Nazi you know like loessa who
wanted freedom for he must have been
kind of a Nazi you can't trust him he's
a nationalist
um there there clearly we can make
reasonable distinctions and when you're
conquering all of Europe that is no
longer a national project and just the
last Point Nazism has nothing to do with
like the great nationalists in the
American tradition like Alexander
Hamilton right it was Alexander Hamilton
a proto-fascist it's it's absurd oh yeah
sorry sorry just just one more thing the
um first line let me see if I can find
it I did think of this but uh you know I
know of no serious historian of the
Third Reich or other thinkers on
nationalism who would go that far
um the first point of the political
platform the National Socialist was
quote we demand the unification of all
Germans in the greater Germany on the
basis of people's right to
self-determination listen they were not
all nationalists or Nazis so they held
true that's that's what Nazism was they
just wanted self-determination for the
Germans that's why they murdered six
million Jews no no so there was an added
element that's not National what's your
master you think Mass murdering Jews is
inherently a nationalistic project no
but I'm saying that to say that Hitler
was not a nationalist is like when
Communists say Stalin was on a communist
just because they don't like what he did
no I said okay in other countries by
definition is not then there is like
nationalism so what's imperialism
between imperialism is the highest stage
in Nationals no it's not as does porch
said yeah
so were there donations within the
Soviet Union the Soviet Union was just a
nation
was France not a nation state when it
conquered a bunch of countries that was
not a national project I think I think I
think we see I think I think we
understand the difference between you
guys on this issue and next question
hi so thank you both for uh spirit and
debate right now just get to your
question sir yeah so my questions for
Alex so one of your uh major arguments
is that nationalism is both centralizing
and and that leads to certain
anti-democratic ruler how do you
reconcile that with the real world
historical fact that many nationalist
movements are decentralizing take
historically like the Habsburg Empire or
today you know catalonian nationalism
oh that's decentralizing uh maybe that I
think that question is addressed to you
rich more than other money should take
it first how do I distinguish between
that I think I understood the question
that that that uh of course there are
many more nation states than there were
uh uh decades ago and therefore
nationalism is then is decentralizing
yeah of course yeah of course yeah yeah
we could have a world of Empires we
could we could have the Soviet Union
again I guess that would be safer
because it wouldn't be it wouldn't be
nationalist right or we could have the
Ottoman Empire we could have the Russian
Empire we could have a huge Chinese uh
Empire that those are inherently
repressive Enterprises so the
Nationalist idea is when you you have a
separate people and their arguments over
what what a people is and what the
Border should be uh but once once you
have that they should govern themselves
and everyone feels this way right we
would not uh enjoy having like a North
American uh Empire a governed from
Ottawa right where we no longer have the
the say and how we govern ourselves we'd
all feel that as a as a grave offense
um now Alex would say oh that's just
Canadian nationalism it's not it would
be North American imperialism and would
be a bad thing people should govern
themselves the um Hitler aside the the
nationalists in the 19th century the
nationalists and the American uh
tradition were concerned with
self-government equal citizenship these
were not ideas that uh the great
Imperial uh projects and Empires came up
with there are ideas that nationalists
came up with and again Alex has to go so
extreme because he can't acknowledge
like anything good about any aspects of
Nations or nationalism because then he
gives away the basic point that their
civic now at the very least there's
Civic nationalism in this country that
we should all uh feel a sense of
attachment to I like patriotism
I'm patriotic I think that's a perfectly
good word that doesn't have all that
baggage or extra meaning say then you're
just playing a word game you're saying
oh so rich calls it Civic nationalism I
call it patriotism so then it's okay but
it's the same thing it's not the same
thing nationalism the country is and
what now I also think by the way Empire
is a bad even when nationalists create
them which they mostly do and try to uh
question next question
um mostly for Alex do you think the
identity politics of the left pose a
threat to the National Fabric and build
a case for the somewhat unifying effect
of a national identity
uh so I don't like the wokism and all
that sort of nonsense
um I think they are inspired by
nationalists by trying to create new
identities based on ethnic and racial
and other side sorts of uh uh silly sort
of uh build walls around to say some
people are better than other people
they're better in these different ways
we're going to have our special
governance and benefits for people who
are part of our tribe
um that's you know they took a Playbook
from nationalists from back in the day
about what these words are and what they
mean and what they're trying to do so I
think it would be great if they got rid
and we stopped pandering to them and if
they stopped uh doing that kind of stuff
but yeah I do think that this woke
nonsense stuff is bad I have nothing
nice to say about so if if nationalism
is responsible also for Nicole Hannah
Jones there's nothing it can't do right
it creates Empires it creates Wars it
creates Nicole Hannah Jones and and
wilkism this is just again it has to be
so extreme because if you realize it
gives just little bit and he's given
away the debate and on the Central Point
Civic nationalism we should feel loyalty
to our nation and its institutions he
has to call it a different word why
didn't you define the Latin root of
nationalism like you did for patriotism
why didn't you do that
well I'll give the game away no because
all all entities so you know what else
is is uh ethnic-based tribes tribes are
ethnic based sex are ethnic uh based the
the point that and all right do we
really want to go to the azir got
section of this debate you know the
scholar he's referring to I have this
book in my bag here and the point he's
making that you distorted uh and you're
writing about this is not that nations
are inherently ethnic based it's every
political entity at the beginning going
back to Time Was ethnic based because we
started as tribes and What You Do you
want to build up from that and get
higher than that with a nation so you
dissolve tribal loyalties you dissolve
uh sectarian loyalties so you all feel a
sense of commonality right we might not
agree on a lot of stuff we might speak
with different accents I'm a
conservative you're a progressive but
there's some thing that unifies us
really deeply in this country and at
this time when there's so much division
that's really important and we shouldn't
be turning it away based on strange word
games
uh it's funny when I wrote about
Arizona's work and I said I think the
United States is an exception to this
nationalist project he actually wrote me
a very angry email uh claiming that
there's an ethnic core in the United
States that is what defines nationalism
here so I think I understood his work
just fine uh next question
so my question is actually for the
negative which uh you and your speech
you say how America is founded on like
democratic ideals like our national
dentist
okay uh are that are uh like national
identity and our founding was democratic
ideals but then you go on to say that
nationalism is sort of a fervor love for
such National ideals so then wouldn't
American nationalism be fervor and love
for a national for our national ideals
of democracy and freedom and not love
for like sadism or other ideologies that
aren't represented within our national
identity
I don't really understand the question
and I don't think I said what you said
well I want to clarify your question and
say go ahead clarify your question so
I'm saying is that uh so our nation as
you said was like an ideological Nation
sort of I was founded on sort of idea oh
he's saying it's not a nation at all
it's not saying it's an ideological
Nation it's not a nation it can't be you
can't use the word a country
it's a state yeah but we're not going to
use the n-word by definition it has to
be something else it has to be something
else whatever you call it okay guys okay
you stirred up some interesting okay so
regardless our country Nation uh was
founded on sort of ideological
principles which are like democracy
Freedom that that's what you have said
and then you've also said
um her nationalism is sort of like a
fervor for sort of like national
identity whether it's like conquering or
other stuff but the difference is that
American national identity is more so
freedom than it is statism as it is in
other places so okay well okay then do
you understand the question now the
common unintended consequences of
nationalism around the world and
frequently by American nationalist
politicians are the ones that I laid out
uh in my points so
um question so just real quick question
would you support the word countryism
sure
what's the Latin root of the word
country
what does it mean so so you're in favor
of countryism it's all the same thing
Civic nationalism is just going to call
it a different word I I don't let's have
an agreement we'll call it Civic
countryism we'll call and everyone can
favor it we can call it patriotism if
you want but using a word that has a
specific meaning that's nasty that's
used by people overseas that is not
consistent with our traditions and this
country that is
identifier is not America it's not
Alexander Hamilton is an American was he
not a nationalist
uh he he uh a lot of people today call
him a lot of American historians call
him an economic nationalist he wanted a
powerful State a centralized bureaucracy
a large government
identity he was on America
uh I would I disagree with his
conception of what the United States
should be by I don't think he was on
America did he want to create like an
epidosis did he want to create an
American ethnic state so nationalism can
be at Nationals can be admirable
I just said that under the definition of
the word nationalist
he is not a nationalist in the European
or in the real definition we're
Americans we're not Europeans I mean
that's part of the point yeah so the
word is pretty yeah okay so why use the
Latin root of patriotism again that
funny foreign word from Europe uh
nationalism is coming back to this you
always obscure this in your talks you're
like oh patriotism is bad I'm going to
use the line word I talk about
nationalism and the origins of it and
what it means you have you have Anthony
Smith's book in your bag
and I never said patriotism was bad when
did I say that okay
guys you denigrate Civic nationalism in
your book I do not denigrate it I say
you actually
came back
there are other parts of it
but Hamilton was a nationalist okay
was not Un-American or threatening
Hamilton was internationalist it was a
status but he was not an international
Alex this is a question for you in the
very beginning of your presentation you
acknowledge that Richard had articulated
a coherent form of nationalism he said
it was benign you didn't say that he's
misusing the word nationalism in his
definition so you seem to acknowledge
that there are more than one sense of
the word uh nationalism
um and also the way you define Classical
liberalism in the American tradition
seemed to presuppose the version of
nationalism that Richard has discussed
in his book
so uh would you be okay with saying or
would you agree with saying that
Classical liberalism and the American
tradition presupposes a form of
nationalism namely the version that
Richard has articulated in his book I
mean my main problem with the definition
in Rich's book is that it Bears no
relationship to how nationalism actually
exists if what he describes nationalism
actually is if you know if he did if
that was accurate we wouldn't be here
today I just you take a look at surveys
of nationalists you take a look at how
nationalist politicians behave and how
they act what he's talking about is
theoretical
okay so if that is the way that it was
um you know we wouldn't be having this
debate but that these are the real world
effects that we're talking about next
question okay I guess this is for Mr
Larry uh the uh in uh Ukraine today
there are many uh people of Russian
nationality who speak Russian uh the
Russian nation state does not uh
incorporate those people so would you
say that the Russian nation-state is
Justified to Annex all Russians
especially when they're a big majority
as they are in in Crimea in eastern
Ukraine on the other hand the Ukrainian
States has this alien element within it
does it have the right to
expel them to or or to transform them to
make them into little ukrainians by
taking their children in the public
schools and beating Ukrainian into them
and taking away their heritage
I think the answers are no and no uh so
I mean Putin's vision of Ukraine having
no uh National legitimacy is completely
correct now life being what it is in
reality being what it is complicated and
messy there uh our our areas you know
where it has more of a case than others
I think Crimea Crimea
um is is the prime example as a
Prudential practical matter would I want
the ukrainians to take back Crimea and
uh provoke a potentially massive uh
reaction for what seems to be not not a
huge strategic prize I I would say no
but um the the even the Russians Russian
speakers now on in the eastern part of
Ukraine want no part of Russia no part
of um of of Russia and
um you know uh the the Ukrainian
government again you know governments
are inherently uh flawed I I by no means
would support everything they have done
or or will do just the basic idea though
so again they're ukrainians they have
this place you called Ukraine the
borders had had been set for quite some
time they should be allowed to govern
there and make uh govern it and make
their own choices and look you know
self-governing Nations they make
mistakes right governments again are
flawed human beings are flawed
everything's flawed things things are
abused even the word patriotism is
abusing become chauvinism right which
Fades into militarism so nothing uh is
is uh perfect but Putin does not have a
right to just and he wanted to take over
he didn't want just you know to secure
Crimea he wanted to take over the entire
country and kill kill us leaders I'm
Coming For You Alex on the question
no okay next question I'm afraid that's
going to have to be the final question
of the evening but uh go ahead with your
question uh yes this is primarily for Mr
Lowry um in your opening remarks you
talked about uh the tribal system of
Afghanistan not quite rising to the
level of a Nation whereas something like
the austro-hungarian Empire would be
supernational
um my question is how can we support
nationalism as a justification for a
state in the associated minimum
requisite coercion uh Monopoly on
violence when there's always a way to
subdivide what a particular nation and
um you know we can craft something of a
national identity for these groups that
want to break off yeah again they're
fuzzy areas life life is uh complicated
you know should Quebec be part of Canada
right has a a distinct culture speaks a
different language this has been a
hugely contentious question
um in in Canada a resolved you know
mostly
um peacefully but so there are always
edge cases but more or less we know what
these uh distinct peoples are Instinct
cultures are and even you know if if the
ball could have bounced a different way
300 years ago the basic nationalist idea
buttressing our International order we
got the borders now and honor them they
are sacrosanct it is wrong it's an
offense to cross someone's else's border
and try to take that territory I think
that's that's a really important one and
it stood Us in in good stead the last 50
years
coming to your house and by Magic a
bunch of nationalists starts to cross
the line and take another nation's
territory they're suddenly not a
nationalist anymore magically somehow
through some sort of transformation uh
is basically the message that I'm
getting from all this
okay
um you uh both gentlemen are going to
come to our after party so those of you
who didn't get to ask a question uh
doing the Q a we'll be able to
buttonhole them they're both very
approachable guys eager to talk about
their particular issues not anymore but
after this debate
I'm still very approachable
um
we now go to the summary portion of the
evening uh five minutes for you to
summarize take it away rich
wow so this exceeded my expectations for
this this debate no this has been
marvelous Alex seriously we got it
spirited there appreciate you appreciate
your passion appreciate your
intelligence and debates like this
they're just so important right I mean
someone should be doing the equivalent
of this on a campus every night to teach
people you can disagree you can talk
over each other a little bit but then
you can go have a drink afterwards and
you can learn from one another you can
sharpen uh your arguments even if you're
not going to change your mind and I'm
not and I'm not so just let me just let
me make my uh I do I do regret now I
dropped out of Latin you know in the the
seventh grade I really really should
have stuck with it I sometimes think
that but then I like no like the process
of learning Latin was not uh was not
great so all right so just just let's go
to another one of these nasty
nationalists uh Jon Stewart Mill you
know figure at the the center of the
classical liberal uh tradition and I
think you put it pretty well you know
what what I'm trying to get at tonight
and this is what he wrote a portion of
man kind may be said to constitute a
nationality if they are united among
themselves by Common sympathies which do
not exist between them and any others
which make them cooperate each other
more willingly
than other people desire to be under the
same government and desire that it
should be government by themselves or a
portion of themselves exclusively again
it gets it gets complicated in the real
world but that's the basic idea it's a
fundamentally correct idea so here we
have this this wondrous Nation this
Bountiful land this diverse and
surprising people of ours these enduring
self-governing institutions government
institutions of self-government that
should have stood Us in such good stead
and we're we're supposed to say no we
can't feel an abiding loyalty to this
nation and institutions and want to
Foster these commonalities for what
right because Trump said something
idiotic because of Adolf Hitler when uh
Democratic nationalist opposed and
thought to The Nail Adolf Hitler so I'll
just submit to you you can be right you
can be left you can be a trotskyite
syndicalist I'm downtown so I just got
to cover my bases you can be in between
and you should still value
this nation care about the interests of
its people so I would urge you to vote
with Washington and Hamilton with John
Quincy Adams and Lincoln with JFK and
Reagan vote to support a common sensical
idea that is a foundation of our
national life together vote not to lose
everything that keeps us caring about
one another and feeling a sense of
community at this time of toxic
political debate honor all those men and
women some known some famous most not
known who cared so deeply about this
nation and made so many sacrifices to
build it so in short please do the right
thing and vote Yes on this resolution
thank you very much
[Applause]
well yeah thank you Rich this was this
was a ton of fun I learned a lot I think
the audience learned a lot they probably
learned a lot more of Latin than they're
accounting on uh sorry about that the
test on the third declension will be
later on at the party
there's a reason why so many people
associate nationalism with so many bad
outcomes around the world of the ones
that I listed and that's because the
common often unintended but the common
consequences of nationalism are the
consequences that I listed big
governments centralized power Central
planning of culture state control of the
over the economy militarism war and
often uh ethnocentric policies that lead
to very bad outcomes part of our nature
though I think is a nationalist impulse
I think this is part of of it for 90
percent of our history or so we grew up
in small tribes in the wilderness
killing each other about the murder rate
was about one percent per year of adult
men it was terrible and you can
understand in situations like that when
we were primitive why these types of
things these nationalism identity would
evolve but as we have a civilization the
extent to which we flourish and are
prosperous and are free is to ex to the
extent which we build walls around build
institutional and cultural walls around
our really bad instincts we replaced a
lot of mysticism with science with
improvements some bad things of course
but some you know largely improvements
we replaced our communal Spirits with
capitalism which has been a tremendous
Improvement and I think to the extent
that we not replace but maybe Channel
these feelings of nationalism Channel
this type of ethnic solidarity and feel
feelings of belonging away from the
government and toward other avenues we
can build a wall around a lot of our
really bad and primitive Natures I guess
I'm sounding a little like Edmund Burke
right here a little bit but there are
lots of states around the world that are
not nation states that are countries
that are free that are prosperous
Switzerland Canada Australia the United
States and yes and New Zealand so these
are all fine countries these are all
fine places to live they're free I'm a
proud citizen of one of them but I don't
think that they fall into the category
of a Nation we need to consider the
downsides of these we need to consider
the downsides of nationalism and compare
to the upsides what what are the upsides
that you heard tonight
bunch of feelings feelings are awesome
I love feelings
got a big heart you wouldn't know it
look at me but I got a big heart I
promise even as a Libertarian I got a
big heart but we should keep feelings
and government separated like we keep
Church in state separated
um
I love my country because it's lovable I
don't love my country because I was born
here or I'm part of some kind of tribe
the United States really is an uncommon
kind of country in the world it is very
very special we're not based on some
kind of ancient tribal ideal or some
mysticism about how versing gettrick
slaughtered or got executed here or
there or all this other sort of
mysticism and nonsense we're a country
that welcomes people from around the
world no matter where they're from they
mold together they become Americans this
is a great country and this stands a
thwart this stands opposed to and this
is not represent a national ideal or
nationalism
um Lowry quoted very nicely the John
Stuart Mill's definition of nationalism
a portion of mankind may be said the
constitute a nationality if they're
United amongst themselves by Common
sympathies which do not exist between
them and any others which made them
cooperate with each other more willingly
than with other people desire to be
under the same government and desire
that it should be government by
themselves or a portion of themselves
unfortunately he stopped quoting there
meldon lists many co-linear causes of
common National sentiment beginning with
of course the effect of identity of
ethnicity and race I'm going to end with
a George Orwell quote
George Orwell wrote quote the purpose of
nationalism of the Nationalist is to
secure more power and more Prestige not
for himself but for the nation or other
unit in which he has chosen to sink his
own individuality I ask you all to
please vote no and don't sink your own
individuality into this abstraction
called the nation thank you
[Applause]
so Jane please open the vote for the
final vote uh nationalism is an
important value that America okay
that Americans should support uh yes no
or undecided on the resolution and while
you're considering your vote uh I I want
to make an announcement about next year
that's January uh January 26th we will
have a debate on the Federal Reserve
George Mason University professor of
Economics Lawrence white will defend the
resolution replacing the Federal Reserve
with free market institutions would
significantly improve the economy's
money Banking and Financial systems
against Columbia University uh professor
of banking and financial institutions
Lawrence Michigan That's Thursday
January 26th go on our website and
tickets will be available but I also
want to make a special announcement
about the new Venture of the so Forum
what's going to which is going to tie in
to that January 6th debate we're calling
it The Soho forums bastiat Society salon
and we're using the term Basquiat
Society because as many of you know the
bastard societies are flourishing
organization that run discussion groups
around the country our new Venture is
going to be the soul forms version of it
we're going to discuss each debate we're
going to have Monday morning
quarterbacking a postmortem on each
debate the first meeting of the soil
forms Society Salon will take place on
Sunday afternoon January 29th a few days
after that debate on the 26th from 2 to
4 P.M prior to that an hour and a half
prior to that I'm going to show the
debate on video because the discussion
will be held at our Loft department at
55 great Jones Street where after party
is going to be Economist Larry white who
will be defending that resolution will
come to that particular discussion on
the 29th to answer questions uh among
the discussions we're going to limit the
membership to 50 people I initially sent
out solicitation to our donors to our
volunteers and to our special
soul from Facebook but now I'm
announcing it to all of you and we will
soon have a release about that
particular debate and the opportunity
for you to buy tickets to that Salon
it's it's going to be nine dollars for
students fifteen dollars for everybody
else just want you to pay a token amount
uh bring your own beer or drinks uh
Refreshments will be provided so I would
like to make that a monthly event
following each debate and hopefully
getting the debater to come but even if
we don't get the debater to come oh we
can discuss the debate among ourselves
and clarify the issues unfortunately
this is the last debate we're going to
have without a salon but we'll have our
big sale on at our home uh shortly where
which both of our Debaters will attend
uh how are we going doing on the voting
Jane still a little bit of time yeah
and while uh the debate well the Voting
is continuing I want to make it just
another announcement uh that we are
again taking a show on the road uh this
coming June for the third year in a row
we will be going up to the porcupine
Freedom Festival in Lancaster New
Hampshire it's almost also often called
pork fest but of course that's short for
porcupine not for pigs uh Jane are you
uh yeah and well I'm going to be doing a
debate up up at the porcupine Freedom
Festival go on the website to buy
tickets to it because it does tend to be
sold out that's going to be in Lancaster
New Hampshire we will be up there at the
porcupine Festival Jane uh okay uh all
right drum roll please okay uh the uh
the yes vote for uh the resolution uh
went from 38.9 to 41.7 percent it picked
up nearly 3 three percentage points
congratulations Rich Lowry Landslide
what
I'm saying that's the number to Pete uh
the no vote went from 22.93 to 44.4 it
picked up 18 votes so the no vote wins
the Tootsie Roll But congratulations to
you both bye-bye
[Applause]